[Music]
not everything goes the way you want it
to go you don't get to choose how life
unfolds you just get to live it
[Music]
looks like i've got good moving water
but it looks like it's out there quite a
ways
right now here in kavik this is the
changing of the seasons winter's letting
go and the springtime is coming in my
list of chores is long but the most
important one that opens up first is get
running water to camp how do i get water
[Music]
i have hose i have to run it all the way
down to the river
put it in the river pump it all the way
up filter it treat it and then send it
around camp where i want it
that's stagnant right there
not interested in that
why is it important to have
rapidly moving water in a stagnant pond
what do you get if you're down south
maybe in the lower world tadpoles slime
you're gonna get sick
so
stagnant water big fat no no
moving water keeps it clean
keeps it oxygenated that's what you want
i've got nice water action coming down
this way
it's moving
i may be able to just
get it right here
the melting ice doesn't have a lot of
issues so what i think i want to do is
get the water line set it out so we can
finish thawing and then go from there
[Music]
you can see my pipe is encased in a
little bit of ice
so my favorite piece of equipment is a
sledge
when you run into a problem you can just
you know kind of sledge it out
alaska is known for its resources
oil gold but the one as residents we
desire the most is that liquid water
that's what we call the gold
i've had a good 9 10 months of no
running water in camp a nice hot shower
is not a bad thing and especially this
last year with kovid the importance of
keeping everything
hygienically clean
can't be overstressed
he said mike doesn't make right
wasn't somebody with a sledgehammer i
guarantee you that
not bad for a fat old chick on the
tundra
that's the pipe and it can lay out here
there's going to be frozen bits inside
even in a cloudy state that sun will
work on that melted so when i need to
use it
it's free of that and it can flow i'll
let this be let nature start working on
it go inside and warm up
[Music]
foreign